it's chilly no question another cameras
already down tough conditions all around
a fill-in just making best what we got
get out get out get out be a camera a
life below zero
everything that's real easy at home it's
20 times harder we're waiting for a
plane to fly through here and drop off
some meds I really hate being on camera
we should do one of these every day
that's gonna be like behind the scenes
around here everything we've got moves
on our backs and there's no room for
error it's time for me to go out find
some meat to do that it means glassing
as much country as I possibly can for me
that means climbing up calico Bluff and
it's steep as you can see up here Zandi
trailblazing us
this is one of the steepest things I've
had to climb on the show so far like
Glasser for every step you take you
basically take two because it's like
walking on a treadmill here we are at
the top of calico about to do our
interview well get some berries
oh yeah that looks great thanks jack
good steady
and here these guys coming down
so how much of the mountain did I bring
back with me let's find out
skate shoes Nick yes maybe I would
choose different Footwear next time
maybe not yeah not so much fun so that's
what we scaled today well we did it good
work boys shooting in Alaska is hard
sometimes I can't even believe I'm doing
this
guns here cameras here we'll see what we
can shoot just down here about two to
three hundred yards away
Glenn recently shot a moose and brought
it back to camp
with fresh meat hanging out the curious
bears that live in the neighborhood are
passing through more frequently
we got a visitor in camp the other night
I was sleeping in this tent now right on
the other side of this wall here is the
cooking station here we've got my bed
slumbering in the corner and here we've
got the paws so the few precautions that
we use are most notably we got our bear
spray here and bear spray is a good
first line of defense this is really
going to get in there and cause a lot of
confusion and turn bears on their tracks
the second form of deterrent that we use
if we have to is a firearm I prefer to
use my weapon as hopefully just a
noisemaker rather than a lethal weapon
you know opportunistic bear might have
thought that that was just a nice easy
way to get its food I'm fine walking on
my own walking it with a camera makes me
less happy fish fish fish there we go
getting footage of Annie and Kate on the
fish wheels difficult and dangerous and
getting back to shore is challenging as
well I don't like that spot right behind
you because that boards
if you step on that it give you a fright
if you were shooting besides a little
slimy that might be my least favorite
part
I've been hazed like walk the gauntlet
and survived cameras and drop in the
water it was all good
you